[Música]
el arte de las películas existe por más
de 100 años
y cómo hacer películas no ha cambiado
mucho de una perspectiva dimensional
poniendo una cámara y apretar grabar no
ha cambiado
el cine sigue siendo una experiencia
frontal
y todavía se percibe como tal
la experiencia de ver películas sigue el
modo de su creación uno se para en
frente de una pantalla y mira a la
imagen presentada
en hecho no hay nada malo en eso a mí me
encanta ir al cine ver películas en
televisión la experiencia de ver
historias en movimiento puede ser tan
poderosa hasta que nos impulsa
emocionalmente
la pregunta que nos hacemos es como las
historias y movimientos pueden existir
más allá de la pantalla plana
si miramos a los medios en el futuro hay
una oportunidad de crear contenido que
se adapte a las nuevas plataformas
cuando firmamos una película
tradicionalmente nos imaginamos una
escena desde un embarque creando
profundidad con primer plano medio fondo
mientras cámara se mueve
obviamente
con los nuevos tipos de dispositivos
como gafas de realidad virtual o
realidad aumentada o plataformas
inteligentes nuevas que nos permiten
navegación en tres dimensiones hay una
oportunidad de empezar a crear contenido
que sea mucho más inmersivo
ya de una manera que nos podríamos mover
adentro y tratar de ver la experiencia
desde una nueva perspectiva no estoy
hablando de videojuegos o de personajes
creados con computadora aunque se vean
super reales estoy hablando de actuación
real actuación de carne y hueso
actuación artística
para hacer una cosa así tendríamos que
empezar
redefinir o pensar nuevas tecnologías y
metodologías para permitir estas nuevas
experiencias
ya estamos y conocemos la afirmación en
360 grados poniendo una cámara del
centro que nos permite crear una imagen
en 360 grados envolvente y nos lleva a
un paso más adelante ya de una
interacción pero
todavía sigue siendo una experiencia
frontal
para empezar a mirar cómo podríamos
meternos adentro de la escena tendríamos
que capturar la luz de todos los ángulos
poniendo cámaras y sensores para poder
capturar toda la luz de todas las
perspectivas con estas soluciones nos
permite recrear el sujeto en tres
dimensiones
vendría a ser como una fotografía en
tres dimensiones en 3-d
esto nos permite no nada más grabar la
imagen en un plano pero sino capturarla
como un volumen esto es lo que llamamos
vídeo volumétrico que es el proceso de
capturar la luz y guardarla dentro de un
boxer
pero que es un boxer
un box él es como un píxel en tres
dimensiones en vez de ser un cuadrado
plano con la información de luz es como
un cubo en el espacio composición x y z
guardando todas las información de todas
las perspectivas esta metodología nos
permite generar un volumen de luz que
puede ser visible de todos los lados y
con esto podemos empezar a pensar y
abrir las oportunidades de nuevo
contenido
obviamente para capturar y crear cine y
escenas historias con este tipo de
solución
tendríamos que crear un espacio que sea
suficiente grande para alojar escenas
sin montar frases enteras y también
suficiente poderoso para instalar
cientos de cámaras y procesar esa
cantidad inmensa de información
parece una idea un poco loca pero es
exactamente lo que hicimos
por los últimos tres años hemos estado
construyendo el estudio del futuro
instalamos cientos de cámaras y
construimos un domo gigantesco que nos
permite crear exactamente lo que
queríamos lo llamamos inter estudios es
la cámara volumétrica más grande del
mundo con el objetivo de desarrollar
investigar y definir nuevas metodologías
para contenido interactivo
pero qué quiere decir contenido exter
activo que quiere decir meternos adentro
de la escena
para probar estas nuevas hipótesis y
ideas
decidimos para la primera vez que usamos
el estudio elegir una escena clásica y
elegimos una escena del lejano oeste
para hacer una cosa así trajimos buenos
escenarios llenamos el estudio de tierra
actores les trajimos como cuatro
caballos realmente para recrear una
escena entera pero esta vez capturada de
todos los ángulos
lo que los actores tenían que hacer para
realmente poder trabajar en estos nuevos
medios era un desafío ellos tenían que
actuar de una manera impecable que se
avista de todos los ángulos ya no hay
más una posición frontal que una nada
mala refiere si no tiene que pensar en
todas las perspectivas muy parecido al
teatro
vamos a ver ahora un poco el primer
resultado que salió
esto que ven acá nos abrió los ojos a
las oportunidades que podemos tener con
estas nuevas tecnologías y medios el
resultado fue un escaneo total y entero
de toda la escena y nos permitió
movernos adentro de una manera libre que
no podíamos antes
con esta nueva solución podemos no nada
más ver la imagen o la luz emitida de
una pantalla sino meternos adentro de la
luz y navegar a dentro del volumen
percibiendo lo de nuevos ángulos
vamos a ver ahora
una de las tomas que renderiza mos
usando esta tecnología lo que van a ver
está hecho totalmente con una cámara
virtual moviéndose en el espacio
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como pueden ver logramos tener con esta
solución un control total del espacio y
del movimiento permitiendo nuevos
ángulos y una libertad para creación de
contenido pero que podemos hacer más con
esta libertad podemos poner una cámara
virtual en los ojos de los actores y dos
puntos de vista lo que pasa que si en
vez del lector elegimos en esta vez el
caballo vamos a ver cómo se podría ver
la misma escena
no hubo una nueva toma pero esta vez
vistas del caballo
[Música]
el caballo no fue dañado en ninguna
cámara fue puesto en su cabeza realmente
esto
libera totalmente las posibilidades de
navegar entre la escena pero esto
obviamente es perfecto para hacer mató
grafos o creadores de contenido que les
da las herramientas para crear estas
nuevas disoluciones pero qué pasa con la
audiencia cómo podemos también
investigar cómo la audiencia se puede
meter adentro
para eso nos asociamos con paramount
pictures para investigar cómo serían las
experiencias y las historias en
movimiento interactivas en unas
películas de hollywood
junto con el director randal kleiser
nos juntamos y recreamos la película
grease 1978 trayendo 20 bailarines al
escenario recreamos la canción judas de
bandera y world en una toma totalmente
nueva
lo que ven acá realmente permitió a los
directores ya nosotros a romper las
barreras de pensar en 2d y empezar a
pensar en una manera totalmente nueva y
emergen nuevas herramientas para el
contenido y la creación de nuevas
historias pero porque verlo de una
manera así plana vamos a traerlos
invitarlos al escenario
no van a venir de verdad los vamos a
traer en realidad aumentada voy a usar
este tablet
lo que estoy haciendo estoy mapeando el
escenario registrando la evolución en
3-d
una vez
vamos a ver qué dicen
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias a los bailes aumentados
como pueden ver
el contenido se fue de fermentar como
una película tradicional o como una
experiencia inmersiva todo depende de
cómo y con qué lo estamos viendo
no estamos tratando de cambiar los modos
tradicionales de crear contenido sino
potenciar los
estamos en un momento único en la
historia del cine
abriendo y entendiendo nuevas maneras de
crear contenido inmersivo
el viaje acaba de empezar
los invito a todos a unirse
y
[Aplausos]